commission president ursula fonda lyon
will deliver the state of the union
address meps will scrutinize the
commission's achievements and plans to
face challenges like the economic
recovery and climate change
meps will debate the situation in
afghanistan following the taliban's
return to power parliament will discuss
protecting people in danger as well as
the humanitarian and migration crisis
in the wake of the kovid 19 pandemic
parliament will vote on legislation to
address future health threats it aims to
strengthen the european centre for
disease control and invest in prevention
preparedness and response
meps are expected to adopt a 5 billion
euro fund to help eu countries mitigate
the economic social and regional impacts
of the uk leaving the eu
the investment will support job creation
businesses and local communities
parliament is set to call for the
phasing out of all animal testing
testing cosmetics on animals has been
banned since 2004 but they can still be
used in scientific and medical research
you